Hello and welcome to mCoding
where we tryto get just a little bit
better at programming every episode.
I'm James Murphy.
I'm using anexperimental editor theme today.
So let me know if it's better or worse than usual.
Today we'retalking about the
algorithm that I affectionately call "fast_pow."
If you're a long-time viewer,you might remember that
I've had a video about efficient exponentiation before.
That videois more about how to find the least
number of multiplications possible
to raise somethingto a small power.
"fast_pow," on the other hand, is a general
algorithm to raise things to verylarge powers.
Of course, if there's a "fast_pow,"
there's probably a "slow_pow,".
And that's the oneyou'd
probably come up with on your first try.
To raise x to the nth power,
we start withone and multiply by x n times.
That means it takes n multiplies overall
in order to raisesomething to the nth power.
The idea for "fast_pow" is that x to the n is
approximately equal to x tothe n over 2 squared.
If n is even, that's exactly correct.
And if n is odd, then we just need
to multiply by another single x.
This is great because it phrases the
answer to the problem
"What's x to the n?" in terms of the
solution to "What's x to the n over 2?"
A problem of half the size.
This lends itselfto a very
simple and elegant recursive solution.
So let's see how to turn this into "fast_pow."
We start off with our base case, which is that
raising something to the zeroth power always gives1.
Feel free to argue in the comments  about
whether this does the right thing for x equalszero.
If you disagree, you could always raise an exception.
We're going to need half the value of
n and the remainder after division by 2.
A bit of Python trivia, though: if you
need both thequotient and remainder,
this is not the best way to do it.
Python has this built-in called "divmod"that gives
you both the quotient and remainder at the same time.
If you're wondering why Pythonwould have a single
function that gives you both the quotient and remainder
instead of justexpecting you to use
divide by 2 and then mod 2,
a lot of integer long division
algorithms,like the one that you learned in school,
produce the remainder as sort of just a
byproductof the algorithm.
So if you compute and divide by something,
you actually get n mod the samesomething for free.
Of course, bitwise operations
also work since we're using two here.
But ingeneral, even if you're not using 2,
"divmod" can give you both at the same time.
Moving on,we
recursively compute x to half the power,
Then square that answer and multiply
byx one more time if there was a remainder.
Otherwise, just return the result.
It's simple,there's a great core idea.
It's very elegant.
And it's pretty easy to code up.
This is somethingyou could
learn as your first recursive algorithm.
By the way, other people call
this algorithm "exponentiationby squaring,".
But that's a pretty lamename.
So I'm going to call it "fast_pow."
So anyway, instead of using n multiplications,
it only uses about log n multiplications.
There are plenty of ways that you could
takethis code and tweak it to go slightly faster.
And that's not really the direction
that I wantto take this in.
After all, Python already has
a built-in exponentiation operator.
And as youcould probably guess,
"fast_pow" is not that fast compared to it.
Although that's due in part
to the fact that the built-in exponentiation operator
uses "fast_pow" or some
more sophisticatedmodification of it.
Now, the direction that I want to take this in is:
What if we allow x to be
something other than an integer.
And what if we allow a different kind of multiplication?
Thisidea and this algorithm don't
really depend on integers or multiplication.
And recognizing thisallows
"fast_pow" to be a more general algorithm.
We'll still stick to non-negative integerpowers.
But other than that, let's
see what else we actually used.
So let's just parameterizethis function
by the kind of multiplication that we want to do.
We'll do this by adding two
new arguments: "multiply" and "identity."
We'll use "multiply" in place of anywhere
that we were going to use the star operator.
And we'll use "identity" in place of 1
because 1 was really specific to integers.
So if we raise something to the zeroth
power,we need to return the identity instead of 1.
The division here is division of the power n,not of x.
So that is still integer division.
We can still recursively use "fast_pow".
But we can't use star equals here.
Star equals is effectively just
saying resultis result times result.
That's squaring the value.
So let's replace squaring the
valuewith multiplying the value with itself.
Same thing goes here; instead
of using the star operator to multiply,
we'll use the mul operator to multiply.
And don't forget to pass the new arguments here.
Now, in order to use our moregeneral "fast_pow"
we need to define this multiplication and identity.
If we wanted to check our implementation,
we could define our multiplication
function tojust take two arguments
and use the built-in multiplication.
The identity for this
is the one that we had here before.
Run it now and all of our asserts pass.
1 to the power of 100 is 1.
5 cubed is 125.
And 2 to the 11th is 2048.
So what other kinds of
multiplications and identity can I pass in?
We just need a multiplication where
we're allowed to put parentheses wherever we want.
That's called associativity.
The other property that we used is that
multiplying by the identity doesn't change the value.
We actually don't care about commutativity
because we're always multiplying by the same number.
Reordering them doesn't change anything.
So we need associativity and an identity element.
Well instead of multiplication another associative
operator that we have is addition.
It doesn't matter where you put the
parentheses when you do addition of integers.
But one is not the element
that does nothing for addition.
If we want adding something
to do nothing, then we should use zero.
Well, then what's "fast_pow" going
to give us in this case.
1 to the power 100 is giving us 100.
5 to the power 3 is giving us 15.
And 2 to the 11 is giving us 22.
Read those numbers again and you realize
that it's actually just doing regular multiplication.
That's right. "fast_pow" on addition gives multiplication.
1 times a 100 is a 100.
5 times 3 is 15 and 2 times 11 is 22.
This is happening because although we
named it 'pow' for power like multiplication
what we're really doing is repeated application.
So repeated application of
multiplication is exponentiation.
But repeated application
of addition is multiplication.
If I repeatedly add 5 to itself
three times that's the same as 5 times 3.
Let's test your intuition.
If we still took multiplication
to mean the built-in plus operator
And we took our identity to be the empty string,
then what would the
empty string to the power of 100 be?
What would 'a' to the 11 be?
And what would 'abc' cubed be?
Answer coming in 3
Answer coming in 3 2
Answer coming in 3 2 1.
The empty string to the 100 is the empty string.
a to the 11 is 11 a's.
And 'abc' cubed is just 'abcabcabc'.
Once Again repeated addition is
basically giving us a form of multiplication.
Multiplication for strings
means repeat this that many times.
This is even consistent
with Python's built-in multiplication.
So if you've ever wondered why a
hundred times the empty string is even allowed,
Hopefully, this gives you an idea that it's
because there's some deeper underlying structure there.
So, I mean cool story, bro.
But is this actually useful for anything?
So far, we've seen a slower version of
the built-in exponentiation operator for integers.
And an even slower version of the
multiplication operator for integers and for strings.
There's pretty much no way that we're
going to be able to build the speed of a Python built-in
using something in pure Python.
So, we need to think about
expensive operations that are not built into Python.
You got it. Here's an example
I think you're really going to like.
Let's start by importing NumPy.
Then let's take our multiplication to be convolution.
Convolution is an extremely important
operation especially in Signal processing.
And it has a lot of the same
properties that the basic multiplication does.
In particular, it is associative.
But there's a problem.
If you've ever looked at the
Wikipedia article for convolution,
you'll see all kinds of mathematical jargon
about something called an approximation to the identity.
Why doesn't Wikipedia just tell me
what the identity is for the multiplication?
Well, that's because there is no identity for convolution.
At least not for real numbers.
Now technically we're on a computer.
And the discrete convolution does actually have an identity.
But for this example, we're going
to be modeling something continuous.
And the continuous convolution does not have an identity.
So, it'd be kind of susque to use the
discrete version of the identity for convolution here.
If we can, we should just not use an identity.
So first, we need to modify our algorithm.
If you had an identity the kind of algebraic
structure we were working with before is called a monoid.
But we can actually get away with even less.
If there's no identity, like there isn't for convolution,
then we can still do 'fast_pow'.
We just need to change our base case.
This is called a semi-group structure by the way
if you just have associativity
and not necessarily even an identity.
So we change our base case.
We now no longer allow raising to the zeroth power.
We just assume or raise
an exception if you want that
the smallest power that
we're going to feed to this function is 1.
x to the power one is just x.
That one is always available.
Once again, division here is division
of the power and the power is an integer.
We no longer have to pass the identity.
And voila. Our 'fast_pow' is now
complete and in its most general form.
As long as you're not raising to the power zero,
this is still going to give all the same answers as before.
But now we no longer have to specify an identity.
Now let's get back to the convolution.
We no longer need the identity.
Then I'm going to take some samples.
And use a discrete approximation of
the uniform distribution between 0 and 1.
Let's pull in matplotlib and plot it.
When we plot it, we just see
a flat line which is what we expect
because it's the uniform distribution.
Every point is as likely as every other point.
Now get ready for the very cool surprise.
What do we get when we use
convolution as our multiplication?
And raise the uniform
distribution to the 30th power?
Are you ready?
Well, what do you know!
Doesn't that look familiar?
Doesn't that just look so much like abell curve?
And there's no tricks here.
There's no e to the minus x squared anywhereinside.
You can run the example yourself.
Let's put that in a loop and see it go slowly.
At n equals zero, we just see the uniform distribution.
Then we see a triangle.
And then each subsequent convolution seems
to give something more and more normal distribution like.
Albeit, shifting further and
further to the right and getting squished.
And the really cool fact is that this doesn't
even depend on using the uniform distribution.
You could pick any initial distribution that you want.
Here, I just took some random formula.
2 * x minus x squared plus 1 for those X is bigger than 0.5
minus 1 for those X's less than 0.1.
So, this formula isn't even continuous.
Divide out by the sum to make the sum equal to 1.
So it's a probability distribution.
And then look at what happens
when we do the iterated convolutions.
As you can see, the blue line,
the initial distribution wasn't even continuous.
But after just a few iterations, we're seeing
that same normal distribution looking shape again.
If you think this is cool,
you should really get into probability.
The theorem I play here is the central limit theorem.
And the reason that this
is somehow related to convolutions
is that the distribution of a
sum ofindependent random variables
is given by the convolution of their distributions.
But that's maybe for a different video.
In any case, I hope you liked "fast_pow".
And importantly, I hope this shows you some
of the potential benefits of beingable to take an algorithm.
And reduce it down to its fundamental pieces.
Abstract awaythe details that you don't really care about.
Is there some underlying structure there
that makes sense in a more general context?
So while "fast_pow" itself is quite a
simple example.
Some of the craziest, most useful results
and very cooloptimizations come from abstracting things
in the same way that we did in thisvideo.
Usually with a little more math, though.
Thank you to my patrons and donors for supportingme.
If you liked the video, don't forget to subscribe.
And if you especially like the video,
please consider becoming a patron on Patreon.
My company is mCoding.
We do consulting,contracting, training,
interview practice, code reviews, that kind of thing.
If you're interestedin working
with me, please check out mcoding.io.
Don't forget to slap that like
button. And I'll see you next time!